TF1 20h avec Roger Gicquel
bonsoir
la France a peur je crois qu'on peut le
dire aussi nettement la France connaît
la panique depuis qu'hier soir une
vingtaine de minutes après la fin de ce
journal on lui a appris cette horreur un
enfant est mort un 12 enfants au regard
profond assassiné étranglé où étouffé on
ne sait pas encore l'autopsie ne l'a pas
complètement révélé par le monstre qu'il
avait enlevé pour de l'argent la France
a peur chaque maire chaque père à la
gorge nouée quand il pense à ce qui
s'est passé à 3 quand il pense à cette
assassin de 23 ans une relation des
parents du petit Philippe un petit
commerçant bien mis qui a fait croire
jusqu'au bout aux parents que l'enfant
était vivant un jeune homme apparemment
sans passion qui ne peut pas
de malade mental mais qui a pourtant
tenu tête avec une froide lucidité aux
policiers qui l'ont interrogé pendant 48
heures quand il était le témoin numéro 1
de la faire oui la France a peur est
nous avons peur et c'est un sentiment
qu'il faut déjà que nous combattions je
crois parce qu'on voit bien qu'il
débouche sur des envies folles de
justice expéditive de vengeance
immédiate et directe et comme c'est
difficile de ne pas céder à cette
tentation quand on imagine la mort
atroce de cet enfant c'est d'ailleurs
probablement pour
soustraire l'assassin à la colère des
habitants de Troyes qu'on l'a mis en
prison dans une autre ville à Chaumont
la France a peur parce que les raptes
d'enfants se sont d'une manière
épouvantable il y en a eu 7 pour la
seule année 75 mais c'est la première
fois depuis 1964 qu'un rapte se termine
au si tragiquement cette année-là Lucien
Léger étrangla le petit lucaron oui la
France a peur parce que comme il y a 12
ans elle ne comprend pas exactement
comme les parents accablés de Patrick
hen
et oui ce qui nous est frais c'est que
ce type ressemble tellement à n'importe
qui et c'est pour ça que la France a
peur alors pour moi cette réflexion elle
était
je crois proche de la sensibilité du
public alors d'où vient le trouble le
trouble c'est que je me suis rendu
compte qu'ensuite ça avait participé
probablement un entraînement de
l'opinion vers ce ce qui était déjà en
gestation ce qui était préparé
c'est-à-dire une un esprit de de
vengeance terrible et de et de justice
expéditive
esprit alimenté toute la journée sur les
radios et plus tard dans ce même journal
par les déclarations de ministres que
vous connaissez
est-ce qu'on peut pas s'interroger sur
le rôle des médias dans ce développement
de la psychose collective de peur et de
vengeance je crois que le crime le crime
existe dans dans la société quand
temporaire
maître Badinter dit qu'il faut
s'habituer à vivre avec le crime parce
que ça existe
il faut s'habituer à en avoir le moins
peur possible mais je crois que
éliminer le crime de l'information
c'est vraiment jouer la politique de
l'autruche il est préférable de traiter
le crime comme une information mais
d'essayer de désamorcer toute cette
panique qu'il y a autour du crime
c'est c'est très difficile à réaliser
parce que
je vis dans un corps professionnel qui a
des réactions et qui sont des réactions
de journalistes qui ne se posent pas de
question il ne faut pas que le
journaliste se pose toujours des
questions c'est presque je dirais qu'il
y a des moments c'est le contraire de
son métier de se poser de question de
savoir s'il doit couvrir tel ou tel
information et il est très difficile de
dire aux reporters d'informations
générales qui sont des qui ne sont pas
des gens assoiffés de sang qui sont
simplement des gens en train de chercher
l'information là où elle se trouve il
est très difficile de leur dire non non
ne traitons pas cette affaire elle est
dangereuse la dangerosité de la
criminalité
de tel type d'affaires on ne la connaît
absolument pas et on n'a pas le droit de
d'indiquer qu'il y aura une une censure
ou une
une rétention très forte et générale sur
ce type d'information
[Musique]